Xiang Chi's conception and evolution in
Marvel Comics has often been admired in
controversy for one reason after another
here are some of the darkest moments
from The Legend of Shang Chi also known
as brother hand the Master of Kung Fu
those who study Shang Chi's design from
the comics will no doubt notice that the
character came to bear more than a
passing resemblance to Bruce Lee in
later years this was no coincidence the
character was created by writer Steve
inglehart an artist Jim Starlin in 1972
to cash in on the popularity of then
novel Kung Fu action films at first
Marvel Comics attempted to secure the
rights to 1972's cult classic Show Kung
Fu to adapt into a comic series when
they failed to get the rights Marvel
acquired the comic book rights to sax
romer's Infamous villain Dr Fu Manchu
thus Xiang Chi was initially introduced
in Marvel Comics as a previously unknown
son of Fu Manchu Marvel's rights to the
character however laps with the
cancellation of Master of Kung Fu in the
80 later writers got around the issue of
not being able to use the name Fu Manchu
by retconning the name as an alias of
Shang Chi's father whose real name is
Zhang Zhu the upcoming live action movie
will keep to this new lore by having
Xiang Chi be the son of Zhang Zhu while
shangshi is acknowledged to be one of
the most honorable heroes in Marvel
Comics that was not the path he was
initially set to follow in the comics
shangshi was born in the Hunan Province
of China where he was trained in all
forms of combat from a young age at
first chongqi was completely obedient to
his father Fu manchu's wishes believing
him to be a benevolent Monarch little
deshong Chi know that his father was
secretly one of the great criminal
masterminds of the world who had been
training his son to be the perfect
assassin and killing machine son
time for you for you your place
inside it was only when Xiang Chi took
the life of Dr James Petri in London as
part of his first mission on his
father's behalf that he began to be
troubled by what he was being asked to
do in the name of Peace there Xiang Chi
met his father's Nemesis sir Dennis
Neyland Smith who revealed the true
nature of his father's evil plans for
world domination aghast at the level of
betrayal Xiang Chi turned on his father
he invaded Fu manchu's Lair and declared
they were now enemies over the years
Xiang Chi would make good on his promise
to his father by foiling his plans for
global domination time and again
shangshi was raised to believe in the
utmost importance of family and his clan
unfortunately that belief became the
bane of his existence once he declared
war on his super villain father and the
rest of his criminal family first among
them was midnight Shang Chi's adopted
brother although the two were not
related by blood a solid friendship had
existed between midnight and Shang Chi
from an early age that relationship came
to an end once Fu Manchu ordered
midnight to hunt down and execute his
Rogue brother although shanxi pleaded
with midnight to renounce their father
shanxi was forced to fight midnight to
the death just as tragic was the
relationship between Xiang Chi and his
half-sister fallacy who was later given
the name Zhang Bao Yu after the
aforementioned rights issue over Fu
Manchu although there was no love lost
between Fu Manchu and his daughter her
desire to take her father down was far
from benevolent fallow C led her own
criminal organization and her plan was
to use Shang Chi to get Fu Manchu out of
the way so her own gang could become the
most powerful criminal organization in
the world once again shanxi was forced
to work against his family when he acted
against his sister as well as his father
you are
you are the legacy of your family
the tragedy of shangshi's entire life
has been that while he is deeply
committed to peace It could only be
achieved through the death of his once
beloved father the super villain Fu
Manchu or so shangshi believed to that
end the 1974 comic series Master of Kung
Fu saw Shang Chi tracked down and
seemingly leave Fu Manchu to die but the
passing of Fu Manchu did not bring
shangchi the relief he imagined after
his father's death Xiang chi embarked on
a quest to save his mother who he
imagined was being held against her will
after a long search he was able to
finally track her down in Master of Kung
Fu number 123 but there Xiang Chi
discovered that his mother was no
captive at all but had truly loved Fu
Manchu his mother renounced Shang Chi
for killing his father the young hero
was given the moniker false Son by his
former comrades and mother the mission
that Xiang Chi believed would free the
world and his mother of his father's
evil failed to be the moment of Triumph
he'd so desperately hoped for Shang Chi
discovered that letting his evil father
die was a more complicated act than he
had imagined in 1983's Master of Kung Fu
number 125 shanxi dealt with the loss of
his family and his own conflicted
Feelings by engaging in the last rites
of his father's funeral to fulfill his
duties as a son shanxi returned to Hunan
to pay his last respects even though he
could not bear to call Fu Manchu
honorable father shangshi nevertheless
prayed that his Spirit would find peace
but his musings were interrupted by
demons both real and imagined chongqi
fled to other parts of China in search
of something that would assuage his
feelings of guilt finally after a
Twilight battle against an assassin sent
by his mother chongqi drinks from his
father's ceremonial cup and is able to
come to terms with his actions to a
certain extent but that acceptance comes
at a price as chongqi renounces his past
as a crime fighter and settles down to a
simple life of farming and fishing
chongqi's personal history has always
been defined by the fact that he is the
only child of his super villain father
Fu Manchu who refused to enter into a
Life Of Crime After chongqi refused his
father Fu manchu's orders to work for
his criminal Empire moving Shadow was
called upon to take shangshi's place at
Fu manchu's side moving Shadow was yet
another half brother to Shang Chi and
raised in a similarly brutal fashion to
be the perfect killing weapon but while
Xiang Chi eventually came to see his
father's evil nature moving Shadow was
blindly subservient and completely
willing to kill his half-brother at
their father's behest in the 2002 Marvel
Max series Xiang Chi Master of Kung Fu
moving Shadow came face to face with
Sean Chi and tried hard to kill him no
matter how much song she exhorted him to
see reason moving Shadow was
single-minded in his desire to kill his
brother in the end shangshi emerged a
Victor in their battle but refused to
kill moving Shadow but their father had
no such qualities dismissing moving
Shadow for having failed in his mission
Fu Manchu personally launched a dagger
into his heart in front of Xiang Chi
chongqi has a long history of being part
of superhero teams where his even
tempered nature and top-notch fighting
skills are invariably assets the 2006
series Heroes for hire saw shanxi
working alongside a host of allies
including the insect-powered metahuman
humbug humbug used to be Buchanan midi
an entomology Professor who turned to a
life of crime to fund his research after
constantly being foiled by Spider-Man
humbug decided to join the good guys
which is how he came to be a part of the
super team Heroes for hire in 2006's
Heroes for higher series humbug gets
manipulated by the alien overlord The
Brood Queen while under the influence of
the queen midi ends up betraying his
teammates to The Brew while the team
escapes the brood's prison chongqi rips
humbug's head off
not a good time to lose one's head
Oh indeed
that's not the way to get ahead in life
one of Shang Chi's most memorable
crossovers occurred with Spider-Man in
2011's spider Island event shangshi
finds himself infected with something
called the spider virus which grants him
similar abilities to Spider-Man but
along with the powers come a series of
disturbing nightmares in which Xiang Chi
sees himself transform into a giant
spider and attack innocent civilians the
vision becomes a reality in spider
Island deadly hands of kung fu when
shangshi is called in to help defeat the
usually heroic bride of nine spiders who
is holding Iron Fist captive after
freeing the other Heroes chongqi
discovers that bride of nine spiders is
being controlled by the god Aya Pike who
has already captured the other Immortal
weapons while battling Aya Pike
chongqi's nightmare comes to pass when
the spider virus mutates him into a
giant spider-like creature the spider's
instincts threatened to consume Shang
Chi's psyche entirely but a last-minute
assist from Iron Fists reminds the
Master of Kung Fu of his true nature in
xiangxi is able to revert back to his
true form despite his youth shangshi's
fighting skills and Serene nature have
made him the go-to guy for Heroes
looking to brush up their skills one
such hero anti-hero was Domino who
sought Shang Chi's help to become a
better fighter and generally a more even
tempered person in 2018's Domino number
four Xiang Chi and Domino engage in an
intense round of sparring at first
shangshi is impatient with Domino's
flighty nature but the two eventually
grow closer even sharing a kiss at a
nightclub unfortunately things come to a
head when the date is interrupted by
Shang Chi's enemies on the orders of
Domino's enemy topaz shanxi helps Domino
recover her lost knowledge of her powers
well enough to take on their enemies
single-handedly eventually Domino comes
face to face with topaz herself despite
Xiang Chi's pleas to show Mercy Domino
was unable to stop herself from killing
her Arch Enemy disappointed with his
pupil Shang Chi dismisses Domino from
his tutelage and their unlikely romantic
relation relationship also ends despite
his extremely violent upbringing chongqi
has managed to stick to a pretty
pacifist path most of the time but the
Master of Kung Fu has strayed from it
from time to time like when he entered
into a pack with the literal Greek God
of War Ares himself the conflict arose
in the backup stories of 2019
swordmaster when Ares and his Legion of
Dragonborn soldiers got into a
confrontation with Shang Chi and
swordmaster ares wanted to get his hands
on Shang Chi's Ally linlier's mystical
sword with which the God of War intended
to kill the kidnapper of his son despite
the misgivings of swordmaster xiangxi
entered into a pack with Ares to Aid him
with the Sword and the retrieval of his
son in return for the god of War's help
in finding Lin lia's missing father
rather predictably the deal goes south
as Aries his son and swordmaster are
forced into a heated battle against Davi
Naka the mother goddess of mad Rapport
although shanxi is able to temporarily
placate the goddess the actions of his
former teammates the Agents of Atlas
lead to an all-out war between the
Surface city of pan and the underwater
city of Atlantis even after
accomplishing his goal of killing his
father and his criminal cohort xiangxi
was not rid of Zhang zhu's Legacy in
2020 Shang Chi series The Master of Kung
Fu discovers that Zhang zhu's Spirit
chose him to be the next supreme
commander of the five weapons Society at
first Shang Chi resists the calling even
after coming into contact with his newly
discovered half-siblings brother saber
and sister dagger but eventually he
agrees to team up with his siblings
shanxi's intention is to rescue his
long-lost full sister shiwa who is
operating as the supervillain sister
hammer and attempting to take control
over the five weapons Society eventually
xiong Chi comes to accept that the only
way to stop the infighting is to accept
his role as the new supreme commander of
the five weapons although he vows to
turn the society into a Force for good
his father's Spirit visits him upon his
coronation mockingly telling him my
drone suits you my son for you are
destined to become like me just like me
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one